[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and today's topic is all
about snow
let it snow let it snow let it snow why
because this year is the winter olympics
and snow has become kind of a commodity
lately there's been less of it in some
places more of it than others and we're
going to devote an entire program on
just that topic i got gary o'reilly gary
always good to have you there man
pleasure thank you bring professional
authenticity to the sports edition
version of star talk being x football
pro over in the uk and of course chuck
knight check hey that's right chuck nice
you're chocolate snowman that's right
not allowed to say that not allowed to
say that you can say it right exactly
like oh my god all right so so here we
go we we've got
ski slopes in the world that should have
had snow by now we're recording this in
january and they don't or there's not
much snow there's a little bit of it
they have these snow machines then
sometimes it's icy and it doesn't
ski the way real snow would and and so
so and climate change is affecting this
of course that's the 900 pound gorilla
behind the curtains and so so so
something is disrupting
our expectations of how when and where
we would get snow
and my wife is from alaska we i get sort
of news from her friends and relatives
who are still there and i learned that
alaska has recorded its highest
temperature ever in the month of
december and it was it was a kodiak
island had 67 degrees something's messed
up so
or it's a new world order that we're not
ready to embrace so since none of the
three of us have any expertise at all in
this uh we have to bring in someone who
does and that is professor peter deals
peter welcome to star talk dude
thanks neil
it's pleasure to be here yeah real
snowman the real snowman okay
and notice chuck he's white
the way it should be
if your snowman is black you live it in
a very polluted area
oh god i'm just i will be canceled by
the end of this year totally yeah if
they'll catch me we will all right
so peter your assistant professor in the
department of atmospheric sciences at
the university of utah uh utah cares a
lot about their snow
and in fact there if i remember
correctly you don't you on your license
plates you don't you have a mountain
range or is that colorado or both of you
uh a mountain range and the state uh
tourism board or whatever trademarked
the slogan the greatest snow on earth
and they have it on the license plates
here
yeah this is this is a place that cares
a lot about snow okay and you're in the
right place because you are co-founder
of a startup company called quantum snow
nice that's
producing fake
powder snow or maybe it's real snow but
artificially produced we'll get to that
in the second segment
but we want to totally learn about how
you got into that and why and what's
different about it so let me just let's
just start out all three of us are
overrun with questions for you so let me
just start out by saying
what's going on
in the world how about this how about
you know
i guess we can talk about what's going
on in the world too but also maybe i can
explain a few you know kind of fun
things about snow and now let's do that
that might kind of focus focus the
questions too because i know what you
mean it's a big atmosphere out there and
there's a lot going on you we've got the
processes and clouds we've got snow
we've got and then the climate change
component of it too which of course we
definitely have to talk about with
snowmaking um but yeah so you know snow
when we talk about
you know these snowflakes those like
perfect star shapes that you cut out in
you know elementary school or whatever
yeah um you know those those six sided
crystals
those form um in clouds that's the start
of a snowflake and those actually form
uh via deposition so the phase change
directly from gas to solid
position thought you meant that a lawyer
actually talked
to
the snow
talk talk to them talk to the to the
moisture yeah no they talked to the
water vapor and right i said yeah
where were you in the night of the face
where were you on the night of the fifth
and then the water vapor goes ah
the gig is up
that's that's a very boring deposition
no this deposition is more fun okay and
just remind me peter a deposition is the
chemical opposite of of sublimation is
that is it is that correct like co2 dry
ice goes right from solid to
gas
and now you're talking about going
directly from gas to a solid state okay
so we're with you now correct yeah
because if you just if you just froze uh
water you know if you just started with
liquid
and then froze it you know
you're gonna take liquid to solid yeah
you just have a ball of ice right that's
what will happen so to grow these
crystals they actually grow
via deposition and so then what happens
in the cloud as they fall through and
then the really cool thing about most
snow clouds is you actually have all
three phases of water coexisting at the
same time so you start so you're growing
via via deposition you're going a solid
flake then it's falling through and you
have super cooled liquid
just to be clear something you didn't
mention
so we are high enough in the atmosphere
away from earth's surface that the
temperature has dropped below freezing
for any of this to happen yes or below
zero c because technically and this is
why this can all happen technically the
freezing point for pure distilled water
is closer to minus 40 celsius it's not
zero celsius
so you could call it yeah the freezing
point of
you know in impure water or or i believe
the word is heterogeneous
um freezing point but every molecule in
it is water there's the water molecule
with nothing else in it
so yeah to to get water to freeze
um you know above minus 40 minus 38 c
you need a seed or a condensation
nucleus
to
start the process of freezing but so
that's why so you have in these clouds
you know you have liquid wow
so i
i did this once okay so we had um
not distill but purified triple purified
water in a plastic water bottle in the
freezer okay and it just sort of
was taken a long time and it wasn't it
wasn't freezing so i pulled it out in
anticipation of this okay
and i
slammed it in the ground opened the lid
allowing impurities again and the whole
thing froze immediately nice
it was a beaut it was a it was a most
beautiful thing it was like it looked
like a like a wave a freeze wave going
through from top to bottom that was fun
yeah but then the only problem with that
is you got to wait a day to drink your
water no i gotta
[Music]
i just wanted my need for water there
right right right yeah so it's too pure
to freeze it was too pure yeah it was
triple filtered yeah it was too pure
okay
yeah yeah you can you can do the same
there's if you shake that too
something about it if you jostle it just
enough one of the you know billions of
molecules
gets into a hexagonal configuration and
that'll start the freezing too like
jostling the water somehow concede the
uh
the
crystallization process now not to
change the subject or to extend the
subject but it seems to me
that can happen on the other end as well
i've had water in the microwave
and i said well that's not boiling yet
all right and then i touch something to
its surface and then the whole thing
rapidly starts boiling yeah so that's
super heat that would be super heated
water because yeah we call super cooled
water water that's liquid below zero c
but is still liquid doctor
the snow doesn't come in just one
standard form you've got all different
types of snow so what is what is going
on to kind of
make those differences happen that's
yeah that's a great question gary so
it's how all of those things
you know interplay in the cloud so
you know you have your your solid
crystal growing but then as it's falling
through you know those super cool drops
those will will freeze instantly onto
the solid flake and so you'll start
getting if you look you know you'll
start getting it looks like kind of fuzz
on those if you if you look at next time
it snows if you look at a snowflake
really closely you'll see so that's
called rhyming and eventually if you get
enough of those on there it just turns
into a ball and that's where like you
see those kind of dippin dots falling
sometimes during a storm that's called
gropple that's where the whole thing has
been covered in those those bits of
rhyme so that's how you get sort of this
whole spectrum of everything but you
said it's called a brothel but what did
you what did you say it was called
that's the kind of snow i want
okay yeah so if you wanna if you wanna
get weird looks next time it's snowing
outside on the street you know collect
some on your sleeve and take a look and
you'll kind of see the
the anywhere from a perfect crystal to a
perfect crystal covered in fuzz to a
perfect you know to a dipping dot and
now what what's you i think you you said
it but once again the big giant fluffy
flakes that fall
and they i mean they're huge that what
would those be
those are a bunch of of crystals then
that aggregate together so an individual
ice crystal you know isn't more than a
quarter inch across so if you get those
big you know like quarter sized half
dollar size flakes falling you look at
those there's probably hundreds of
individual ice crystals in there that
have kind of stuck together
oh that's kind of cool man yeah yeah
yeah it's i get made fun of a lot
because i whenever it's snowing i
collect them when i sleep and i look at
them but you know you get used to that
kind of thing in science
you have been able to produce powder
snow correct
correct yeah so
and that
i got to tell you something i'm sorry
doc but uh
i too was able to produce powdered snow
and it got me five to eight
i had to do it i'm sorry and then anyone
else not surprised i couldn't do it
anymore listen that's my one and only
snow joke and i was holding back
you said powdered snow i couldn't help
it gary okay okay so chuck we'll give
you credit for having held back this
long exactly
all right you've made powdered snow
and that is if i'm right thank you if
i'm not correct me please that's five
percent density
that's yep
so if we did
so that's downhill skiing say
snowboarding or cross-country skiing is
it are you going to be using the same
sort of five percent density snow for
those events like ski jump or anything
like that that's a great question that's
cool yeah yeah or does each event have
its own unique snow quality yes that you
could possibly dial up if you're
bringing it in from the outside
but only better yeah this is no this is
perfect so this is right where now since
we're technically sports and science
this is where the snow intersects the
sports so
our so the snow that we've been able to
produce yeah it's five percent density
it's light it's fluffy the snow that's
produced by traditional snow making is
just blowing water droplets out of a
hose getting them as small as possible
and then those freeze and sort of
miniature tiny bbs and stack up and
that's you know sufficient for
for skiing in fact that's actually for
the olympics first particularly ski
racing events they actually want
you know that icy dense snow that's
produced by traditional snow making in
fact
ball bearings because you're just you're
rolling on the on the spherical frozen
bits of snow doesn't it well it's
actually yeah i mean sort of
so the way that i understand it the way
that that skis work with snow i think
it's the same with ice skates is that
when you're applying pressure on the
surface you are locally lowering the
melting point
such that you have a thin
film of liquid water that
you're allowed to glide on and that's
what you're really gliding on is the
water yeah
then the ball bearings yeah okay skin is
nothing but surfing on land
yeah there you go that's really the deal
yeah but you know when you talked about
the small droplets freezing
and then uh being the surface on which
to ski
if you're downhill skiing the good thing
about that is the icy element of what
you just described little balls of ice
allows you to cut into it when you're
turning so they want that kind of you
know more dense somewhat icy because you
need almost like a blade on the
inside of the ski
to grip and that allows you to do the
slalom and this is the only show ever in
the history of the universe where a
black man is giving skiing advice
oh that caught me by surprise
you got me i got that i'm going to let
that comment section you got me that was
good okay
i started touching that
so doc
here we go our audience are going to
want to know this
is a
every snowflake unique in its shape
and in the snow that you make are you
making unique crystals or are you just
producing clones
clones oh
that's a dig right there that's no
that's a great question gary
um i believe every snowflake
is unique just because you know the way
these individuals
you heard that he says i believe
so peter i didn't know it was a religion
right
when i say i believe that's for that's
science for
i'm like gathering things that i know
and hoping that i'm saying the right
thing
and one of my colleagues might comment
on this
podcast and say that
you know i was wrong and they can be
you know identical but in nature
i think
because you know you're stacking these
molecules
according to these conditions and the
conditions are varying you know so
so much throughout
your you know at a molecular level
you're not going to stack these
molecules in the same
form and crystallization is chaotic too
you know small changes produce these
non-linear you know feedbacks and so
yes our crystals because they're formed
by by deposition by that solid or that
vapor to solid transformation and in
nature all those are forming uniquely
because of this non-linearity of
crystallization so peter i did a
calculation once i computed how many
total snowflakes have ever fallen in the
history of the world holy crap right and
well you can estimate you can they're
ways to estimate that and plus here's
how he ends this story and that's how i
spent my entire teenage years
so so that gives you a base number and
you can ask
how many molecules are there of water in
a crystal of water in a single snowflake
and the number of molecules in a
snowflake
exceeds the total number of snowflakes
that has ever fallen uh so sorry not
just the number i wrap my head around
that the ways that they can
configure
and so you're looking at the a at a at a
it's a probabilistically you can look at
how many total outcomes are there among
the molecules as peter was describing
compare that to the total number of
snowflakes that has ever fallen and one
number vastly exceeds the other so you
can say with good confidence that no two
snowflakes are alike even though you've
actually never checked it that's right
we gotta take a quick break but when we
come back more with uh professor peter
veals who's one of the world's experts
on not only what snow is but on how to
make snow we're gonna find out more
about that and what that has to do with
the future of snow sports especially the
olympics when star talk returns
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about snow
and where it comes from and why and
where it's going and why and where has
it been and what and shouldn't it be
there and how come
there's a lot of like issues we have
today with regard to snow for example um
gary did you one who told me that in
vancouver
uh yeah thank you hoover olympics what
happened there 2010 vancouver
was snow poor so they had to airlift
snow in they had to truck snow in
because it wasn't falling out of the sky
for free so
so this this made us think so we got the
star talk lens out and we just look
through it the way we do
at winter olympics and you know snow
stressed events and if you look at the
winter olympics coming up in 22 in
beijing in china
we might have issues but let's ask the
doctor really what he feels peter peter
veals assistant professor of atmospheric
science university of utah so so peter
uh what's
it sounds like there's a huge sort of
industry of people putting snow where it
needs to be and
can snow be treated like sand for
example there are beaches that have lost
sand and others that gain it and so they
just sort of
bust the sand from one beach to another
to
even that out again and it gets sold and
there's a it's a commodity really so is
that what snow is today
yeah i mean
in some sense although you know the way
snow is made has been made traditionally
you know for the last like 50 years is
you set up this vast infrastructure on
the mountain of
high pressure hoses you know they're set
up along a run strategically and then
you have compressed air and water
running into those and you're blowing
these droplets out and so
um you know
they rely on the air
being below freezing in order to freeze
correct
somewhat yeah so it's it's there's two
things that the compressed air does one
it helps fracture the water into the
tiniest possible droplets which will you
know freeze more readily before they hit
the ground and provide a better skiing
surface and then also
as the the pressure drop coming out of
the hose leads to a rapid temperature
drop which also helps freeze those
that's how refrigerators work that's
very good yeah right that's right so in
a refrigerator you have the coolant
which
is compressed by the compressor
and as it comes out the other side the
rapid expansion cools it well below
freezing and then you extract um
that very cool
region of the
is it the coils um then sucks the heat
out of the refrigerator it
changes the state of the coolant again
and then you gotta go back and compress
it so this is basically a bit of
technology borrowed from your
refrigerator
right
right although you know that's so that's
what traditional snow making does our
our snow making method you know that i i
developed through my my processing
company actually um uses um
actual refrigeration so
there's they're similar to to
refrigeration and then there's actual
refrigeration too but
is this something that you you know
you get on a bath phone and they call
you know professor veals and then he he
shows up with it with a machine or is
this something that they can embed
permanently in snow banks i mean on some
ski slopes yeah this will require our
the method that that we developed at
quantum snow will require similar
infrastructure to you know what's set up
on these mountains you know where you
have
um you know air and or you have you know
water and and power lines and mounts you
know steel mounts and also so why is why
is your method better why do we need you
i'm already so
yeah
this is where um you know it's we
we differ from the olympic kind of
requirements here so for the olympics
like i was saying you know you want they
often want very dense icy snow because
allows you to ski fast
and to dig those sharp steel edges into
the snow but for recreational skiing
people want that really light fluffy
snow you float nicely on top when you're
skiing down it feels really cool you
know it feels almost like flying to be
honest i know it sounds cheesy but just
you know you can be going 40 miles an
hour and feeling almost weightless and
you can turn and you know swoop however
however you want to and so
people pay huge money to ski snow like
that's the sound of fresh snow yeah yeah
it's all about the fresh powder it's
like because everybody wants to be
in the youtube video where the guy drops
out of the helicopter skis down the side
of a mountain and it's leaving a trail
of what looks like smoke because that's
how light and fluffy the powder is
yeah yeah and where is the panel
everybody except me who wants to just be
at the bottom of the mountain
inside
how was your ski
so doc
can you produce snow and and leave a
carbon neutral footprint just like it
would if it fell out of the sky
yes you can you just have to have you
know the the power the electricity that
is required for snow making you have to
have it come from renewable sources you
know and right that's similar you know
i've i've heard a lot of questions about
you know the ethics of snow making
um
and
you know if you think about it it's not
wait wait wait wait i've never heard the
word ethics and snow in the same
sentence
right there's like the ethics of you
know crime and punishment and snow okay
so
i i actually get what you're saying when
you say the ethics of snow and i'll just
give you a quick aside there's a
commercial running right now i will not
say the car company but the person lives
in california clearly uh and they pull
up to their driveway and they have a
snowmaker for the kids and the kids step
out of the car in their sandals and
they're stepping on snow and of course
because they're raised in california
they don't know oh my god this stuff and
the first thing i thought was so you
guys
actually used up
all this dirty electricity
and you're touting an electric car
you know so like it's that kind of
juxtaposition yeah yeah exactly and
there's the thought you know with
climate change you're like well it's
getting warmer and nature's taking this
thing away
and then you're using electricity which
is you know if it's not coming from a
renewable source which is contributing
to the climate change problem you know
you could you could see that you know
being questionable but the trick is like
anything
you know it has to come from a renewable
source and there are a gazillion things
that humans do
recreationally that
are you know irresponsible from an
energy perspective you know just the
existence of las vegas or dubai
july is irresponsible you know if people
like jeez i mean
this is desert no one will want to live
here let's just make a desert
bam vegas all right you know you know
they have an indoor ski slope in dubai
exactly
here in jersey
yeah
seriously about about 15 minutes from my
home it's a jersey isn't in a
desert right which makes it even worse
okay so let's get back to let's get back
to what is the ethics of snow yeah so
yeah so you think about yes you are
using energy to produce a thing that
people enjoy but like jeez if we can't
use any energy to produce anything that
people enjoy that's that's air travel
that's like going to the movie theater
it's everything it's driving someone you
know like
at
some level the human existence requires
energy you know for food but also
recreation and so the trick is to just
power everything with renewables that's
right so so it's all about once again
changing the source if you change the
source then you you solve the problem
right right okay right by the way when i
first drove the tesla roadster this is
early on when not even many models had
existed uh there was a one at a power
plant and it was plugged in to one of
their ports that actually generated
energy through solar panels
and so i so when i test drove it in that
moment i said this just feels really
like i feel good
not in the construction of the vehicle
but in the power used to drive it i just
i had an extra feeling of goodness about
that but let's get back to
why your process is different
so
uh yeah it goes just right to the
molecular level we grow snow via
deposition
and traditional snow making is just
grown
via freezing of liquid
okay it takes time i know i learned from
my eighth grade chemistry class it takes
time to grow crystals
right okay much more time than it takes
to freeze something and you also need a
low pressure system moving in from the
north
[Laughter]
chuck you got a future that's good
that was good
such as a plus on that one so so so how
do you do this fast enough to be
functionally useful on a ski slope so
without giving away sort of the
the trade secrets of quantum snow
we just had to develop a way to do it
that was
as fast as possible per unit area you
know or per unit volume and then you
scale that up to a large enough machine
okay so if you don't give away the trade
secrets let me just ask you
um
how long does it take you to drop an
inch of snow over oh
yeah that's a perfect startup and
scaling question because right now our
first prototype is this little you know
glorified mini fridge that i built
partly in my garage and partly in the
lab here at the university and
i mean it would it would drop a
centimeter of snow in that chamber i
mean it would take like an hour because
that was our demonstration proof of
concept prototype so you know with
startups every step you're scaling up
right
you're faster you're larger volume
you're cheaper more economical so what
we're working on right now is our next
prototype which actually works outside
you know it runs up and down a short
little slope so someone could actually
turn once or twice in it and
the spec that we have for that that i'm
working with we have some awesome
engineers that that came on board and
that we're working with is um
about an inch an hour that we'd be
laying down the snow okay so they do
this overnight then they do this
overnight right yeah right but even if
we can and yes an hour is a lot of snow
if you have a storm that moves into your
area and it's dropping an inch an hour
that's a that's a it's a real storm yeah
that's that's a that's a very good
analogy there chocolate how about
chuck's got some random great weather
knowledge that he just pulls out
he knows way too much
it's totally he was totally right it
didn't change there's way too much about
skiing
equipment what size equipment do you
need to produce an inch of snow because
it's not like excuse me
2.54 centimeters of snow okay precisely
okay let's keep it metric i'm english
and i'm in america so essentials so
you know you're not like ghostbusters
you're not turning up and just producing
this off a backpack can you you know you
can if you're gonna do scale you're
gonna need large equipment and that's
just you're dragging it up a mountain
right right exactly yeah although i mean
the equipment that's used now for
snowmaking the great thing is we don't
have the bar is pretty low for our
competition because you know a lot of
these mountains these big ski resorts
they have an entire like warehouse size
room that's all giant compressors it's a
giant like compressor factory and they
run these compressed airlines all up
over the mountain they spend a million
dollars worth on power bills and you
know they use like
billions of gallons of water millions of
gallons of water you know i don't know
the scale on that but billions feels a
little high there but yeah maybe million
we'll say millions especially since an
inch of water makes 10 inches of snow so
right the billion is well
of the snow that you know quantum snow
is trying to make the current snow
making you know where you're blowing
these droplets out of the hose that's
going to pack much more densely that's
like a 50 density versus ours is like a
five percent density so yours is much
closer to authentic snowflakes that's
what you're saying
well wait how about this how about this
if one of your snowflakes fell on my
shirt
and and a real snowflake would i be able
to tell the difference
uh you would not
as long as the other snowflakes so when
they fall they'll often you know
snowflakes are really delicate they'll
hit and they might break in half or
something ours resemble like a half of
this six-sided crystal
wow you guys are like the like the
diamond growers of snow
because that's exactly what they do when
they're
when they grow diamonds you know
right exactly yeah and there's a lot of
cool like you can really geek out on
crystal growing processes you know like
when they make jet engine turbines they
want the whole thing they don't want any
seeds for any crystals they want the
whole thing to be one crystal because i
guess it's uh less prone to shatter yeah
like when they're cooling the metal yeah
there's all kinds of
like this process of seeding or not
seeding a crystal as like something
turns into a solid is like a really cool
branch of chemistry that i didn't really
ever think i'd be into okay so we've got
we've got the beijing olympics for the
winter olympics and
are we going to find ourselves sort of
returning to the vancouver 2010 scenario
and this being a snow poor
tournament event so yeah you're that's a
great question gary you're going to be
shocked i think all of us are going to
be shocked when we see the mountain
range northwest of beijing at how little
snow there is like some of these places
the nearest climate sites get like a few
inches of snow the whole winter this is
like an extremely cold and dry mountain
range but the trick is that it's cold so
it's a perfect place
for them to make this artificial snow
but it'll just look kind of bleak
because you'll have like potentially
bare ground or maybe an inch or two of
natural snow along as the camera zooms
back
out then you see that
mountain you have a snow striped
mountain yeah yeah exactly they call
that the white ribbon of death in the
skiing world you don't want to fly off
the side because you're just going to
have rocks on the side so it's it's it's
mountain pattern baldness
yeah
yeah wait so so let me just ask before
we we close this out some places are
getting
higher than normal
average amounts of snow
so is this just a redistribution of snow
in the world or is there any net total
change
from climate change effects on the world
exactly
so
i that's a great question in fact and
gary what's that place you mentioned and
you found in the notes
oh see i'm in chicago right end of 21
chicago had no snow in the latter half
of the year until december 28th they got
their first dusting of snow so they went
through a snow drought
like tahoe got a 50-year record high of
16 foot of snow
in december
so you've got this
big snow dump in one place and a snow
drought and yeah so so how does how does
that reconcile with our thinking about
what the global warming so yeah often
you know the general the general pattern
is going to be yes more extremes right
of of drought and you know plenty of
pluvial with the snow you know large
snow falls but then of course when you
talk about the average
you know places that are very cold are
typically very dry and so actually as
you warm those places as long as you're
not warming them above freezing
warmer often means more moisture in the
atmosphere so a lot of the very cold
places on earth are actually going to
get more snow as the climate warms
interesting and then that's on average
of course but there is places you know
with more marginal snow climates are
going to get less snow on average
okay now this also affects the water
tables right because the snow collected
over the winter on mountain slopes melts
and goes back down into the valleys and
so there's a whole hydrology
equation that civilization depends on
right that that's going to get disrupted
as well yeah and that's that's what's
most important because it's a snowpack
and the way that it melts it melts over
time as opposed to rain which just all
comes at once
right exactly yeah and you know i think
i think that's a great tie-in too with
snow making because that's part of the
ethics of snow making also is you want
to use less water because if you're in a
place that's getting less water you know
from natural snow
you are using that also to make snow but
yeah in you know in all of these these
mountain ranges of the world that's
going to be a big question you know it's
interesting we're dealing with this very
cold very dry set of mountain ranges
northwest of beijing because those are
potentially one of the few
kind of climates of the world that could
benefit from a warming climate the key
is few you know the vast majority right
of these mountain ranges are are not in
for great things as the climate warms
but um
yeah you really it's it's a big deal for
all
all of humanity to have mountain ranges
getting
less snow and snow packs that are
melting sooner well that's the note
we're going to end on peter this has
been a delight to speak with you uh we
love this kind of obscure expertise
kind of you know
anytime you can make snow
interesting
on a molecular level yeah i mean you're
doing something great man
we good so peter how can we find you and
you're on social media yeah yeah so um
i'm on uh twitter at p veals and then
quantum snow is on instagram at quantum
underscore snow
nice nice so when you guys go public
give us a call okay
yeah actually
i know you're not supposed to but do us
a favor before you go public exactly
exactly and that's the way i want to
roll
don't be shy
oh thanks guys this has been right
excellent peter we're out guys we gotta
take a quick break but when we return
we're gonna have professor twyla moon
as our guest and she's one of the
world's experts on glaciers
big hunks of ice made by snow
so peter we're gonna say goodbye to you
here it's great to have you on and uh
stay with us we'll be right back
we're back star talk
let it snow let it snow let it snow
that's our running theme and we've got
with us for this segment the dr twyla
moon did i pronounce your first name
correctly there you sure did
excellent excellent i'd love your last
name by the way but that i'm just i see
what you did there
i see what you did there neil
i'm just saying i just i can't let that
go
i can't let that go and and you could
tell people i'm going through a phase
you know this is oh no
okay
so i i got this this this brief bio here
is just stunning that anyone in the
world has this expertise and it's like
if no one did you'd have to invent that
person because
she's from national snow and ice data
center
university of colorado deputy lead
scientist at the cooperative institute
for research environmental studies at
the university of colorado boulder of
course it's a boulder a ted talker at
tedx big sky
but you're an expert in ice dynamics
glace
glacial sea ice interactions glacial
hydrology and all things glacial so i
love it because glaciers are this or
this otherworldly thing that we don't
think about here in the in the lower 48.
my wife is from alaska she thinks about
glaciers and so i'm delighted to have
you on star talk thanks for being here
and don't forget to mention uh you know
that she's an expert on the cryosphere
and then i'd like to ask what the hell
is the cryosphere
right exactly all of you are thinking
about uh
putting in for your uh your future lives
in 100 years of being frozen but no the
cryosphere is all things frozen in the
earth system so we've got sea ice we've
got land ice which is glaciers greenland
ice sheet antarctic ice sheet snow
frozen ground which is also known as
permafrost
so there are a lot of icy bits or
cryo pieces in the earth system and we
call them all together the cryosphere
okay gary and chuck what's really going
on here is if global warming completely
plays out
she's out of a job because there's
nothing left frozen in the world yeah
and there's nothing left there's nothing
left of us anyway so
it's a good time to be out of work
i'm gonna be setting sail that's what
i'm going to be doing oh there it is so
so twilight tell me
uh the
remind us all
what a glacier is
as you walk by it it looks like there's
chunks of ice
so when we think of ice we think if you
take water and freeze it but a glacier
is not exactly that it's something else
so this reminds us what a glacier is
yeah and actually another thing that
sometimes gets confusing is sea ice so
people talk about the ice cap in the
north and often actually what they mean
is sea ice ice that has formed from
freezing ocean water and sits on the top
of the ocean but what we have with
glaciers and that broad category just
before you leave that subject yeah of
course
santa claus's entire workshop is on sea
ice right he's on the north pole and no
one ever
i i i tweeted at one point i said how
come every time you see santa claus in
his workshop there are trees and
mountains in the background this this
sucker's on the freaking north pole and
that's it that's a an ocean the arctic
ocean and if he's on anything any
surface at all it's ice
yeah you are absolutely right there
santa in the north pole should be
hanging out on ice i did see norad
tracked him taking off from an airport
in northern greenland this year so you
know probably
to keep some of that transportation on
land rather than a mobile ci okay so
tell me so what's what is a glacier yeah
this is formed from snow so the whole
point of building a glacier is that you
have to have enough snow falling in
winter that it's going to stick around
the following summer and then get more
snow piled on top of it and so you get
layer of snow layer of snow layer of
snow and over hundreds and then
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
years all those layers start to compress
and they become more dense and they
become glacial ice and uh glacial ices
uh has more water but more air bubbles
than like the ice in your freezer and
those air bubbles we use for cool
science too so glaciers and the world's
ice sheets greenland and antarctica they
are all formed from
year after year of snow building up and
one of the cool things so you're seeing
snow under pressure that becomes solid
looks different
from an ice cube i just made in the
freezer that's what you're telling me
yeah exactly because as that snow is
getting compacted it tends to keep some
of those little air bubbles in it and so
actually after a couple years as that
snow becomes more dense it becomes
something that um glaciologists call
fern f-i-r-n
and then it takes a bit longer for it to
become even more compacted and then it
becomes glacial ice and that glacial ice
is going to have lots of little uh bits
of air in it and
big ice crystals which help to give it
that blue color this is how when you see
the scientists drilling down and taking
out those super long cores
they
at that point they can actually find air
if you want to call it that from like
hundreds of thousands of years ago and
then they could tell how much carbon was
in the atmosphere by those little
bubbles that are all the way down at the
bottom of those cores
absolutely so this is how we know eight
hundred thousand years of climate
history thanks to ice
wow
that all right wait a minute let me do
it let me do it guys i gotta do it
damn that's cool
are you happy now
are you happy now you got awesome
have you have you scratched guys have
you scratched that are we done here
chuckling i know i know it was terrible
but i haven't
done okay there was the ice cream in the
freezer you had to have it yeah so
okay so let's think
just in the last 10 years doctor um
snowfall patterns seem like they've
changed and we've got the remnants of
hurricane larry in september 2021
drifting up towards greenland and
depositing snow in september are we
seeing a lot of changing patterns now in
greenland's ice and snowfall and
therefore this sort of
continuation of snowfall to produce
glaciers has that been affected
dramatically
yeah absolutely we've seen really big
changes um not just in snowfall but
actually more in temperature and the
arctic where greenland sits is warming
faster than any other part of the globe
some of that big warming is in winter
unfortunately it's still cold enough
there in winter that we're getting snow
in winter but now more and more in
summer we have long warm melt seasons
and that means that now every year since
1998 we've been losing ice from the
greenland ice sheet and that has been
transforming that so just to be clear
when it is announced that the
temperature of the earth has risen by
whatever fraction of a degree that's an
average right and so
so
the an average would have the numbers
below it and numbers above it the
numbers that are significantly above it
if i remember correctly are all polar
so the biggest temperature shifts are in
the polls damn and that you don't even
think about that because you're well
they only report the average is that
correct
yeah that's absolutely right um war
means actually stronger on land than
over the ocean and warming is stronger
in the arctic than in other places
around the planet oh that's just
bad news okay is greenland getting a
positive mass balance in terms of its
ice sheet and the replenishment of snow
yeah so i like you use this phrase mass
balance and that is sometimes confusing
it's basically we measure kind of
starting in fall as the ice sheets
starting to get snow and then through
all the way through the next summer how
much mass of ice is it getting in winter
and then how much mass of ice is it
losing in summer so that's the mass
balance and because we're losing ice
overall it's a negative mass balance and
that has now been true for
more than a couple of decades for the
greenland ice sheet so the coast and the
shape of the greenland ice sheets been
totally transformed and then of course
that's also transforming our coastlines
uh in places very far from the greenland
ice sheet when you talk about land ice
what you were what you just mentioned
and i don't want to mess this up so i'm
going to let you guys take this
neil and i did a thing where we were
talking about
sea ice and the melting of sea ice but
the volume of ice when water freezes i
don't know if it's the same for when ice
has salt in it or saline
but it becomes bigger so when ice melts
in liquid
it actually has less volume
and
so what does that do for the rising of
sea levels if i ask that question
correctly if not then please explain the
two scientists here because i don't know
what the hell a minus you get an a minus
i get a minus okay i'll take a minus
okay
yeah so when we think about uh melting
and formation of sea ice the biggest
impact factors there are not sea level
because we're freezing ocean water and
then we're melting that
ice that was formed from ocean water and
so there are some little changes in sea
level rise but that's not what you're
writing home about but when it comes to
losing ice from glaciers or from the
greenland or antarctic ice sheets
because that ice is sitting on land
it's all of the water that we lose as
that ice melts is getting newly added to
the ocean and so we're really increasing
the volume of the ocean
in a way that we just aren't when we
when we are melting sea ice so you're
not just turning on a spigot here
because the water is the oceans are
sailing but glaciers are pure
it's pure fresh water water
yeah fresh what's the word it's pure
fresh water so you're actually
diluting
the ocean with fresh water for doing so
is that is that
yeah that can't be that can't be good no
yeah it makes changes to ecosystems i
mean in greenland the one of the biggest
industries there is fishing and uh what
those ecosystems look like as far as
ocean temperatures and also salinity and
fresh water are changing but it also can
impact some of the big ocean circulation
systems we see as we add fresh water to
those so
yeah it's not just the volume of losing
this ice and adding it to the ocean but
it's also that it's fresh water instead
of saline well let me let me show off in
front of you i i i try to use this word
in a sentence so does that disrupt the
thermo haline
[Music]
circulation
yeah
yeah wait a minute wait a minute is that
the world going bald the thermal
hairline the thermal hairline
is that the world just going bald
i'm telling you the world's worried
about it
we know about ocean currents moving
horizontally but there's also
the ocean currents going top to bottom
right
and so and they're fishes that need or
require that so do you care about fishes
at all do you have colleagues who you
collaborate on with that i have
colleagues who i collaborate on that um
so i'm i'm not out there collecting fish
on in my research directly but it's all
a connected ecosystem so we have to be
talking with each other the people who
are studying the fish and the big marine
mammals and the ice and what's happening
with snow and the atmosphere so it's all
connected doctor how fast the glaciers
move
and
if if we
why why
why do they move at all you're telling
me it's ice i'm fine with ice now you're
going to tell me it's a river
so
and actually that's one of the primary
requirements for ice to be a glacier is
that it is moving um because ice is
still
mobile and when you have so much of it
built up you start to create deformation
in that ice and so it does move like a
really slow river and then sometimes
depending on the interface between the
ice and the ground underneath it it
might also slide on that surface so
lubrication down there yeah so you can
have kind of a
wet surface between the ice and the and
the land underneath it and so glaciers
do move it's absolutely necessary for us
to call them a glacier and
there are a wide variety of speeds in
which glaciers move there's
around the greenland ice sheet you can
kind of imagine it like a big reservoir
of ice and then it's got all these what
we call outlet glaciers kind of like if
you had an outlet stream you know
draining water from a lake but we have
hundreds of these outlet glaciers all
around the edge of greenland and some of
the fastest ones move 15 16 kilometers
per year so they are really driving that
ice from the interior of the ice sheet
out into the ocean by the way i'm sorry
i went to uh i went to public school
here in america what is 15 kilometers in
way i could understand
that's going to be somewhere around 10
miles okay for a year 10 miles that's
pretty impressive
now
there's some a cartoon where somebody's
running and the glaciers chasing them
you know down the valley you know
freddy krueger of glaciers
if if greenland's glaciers are
responsible for i believe something
close to an inch in the rise in sea
levels over the last 15 years
is there a possible way to slow them
down because there's something called
geoengineering is there not
that does things that slows things down
or can
push back or
you tell me because you are the expert
here yeah so geoengineering is a word
that creates a really big umbrella and
there are lots of things that count as
geoengineering there are some things
that are already things we're really
hoping will work like capturing carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and storing
it away in the earth in rocks or
something like that we really want that
technology to work because that is part
of our plan for keeping global warming
under check
but there are other parts of
geoengineering that i personally don't
think are very good idea and they tend
to be things that are like oh let's
build something really monstrous to hold
back the ice over here
but we're sort of forgetting about the
scale of ice so the greenland ice sheet
covers the world's largest island the
antarctic ice sheet is a whole continent
and
i don't see a space where the
construction and the finances are trying
to to change these ice sheet behavior is
going to work out for us
the chinese built a three thousand mile
wall
fifteen hundred thousand years ago land
right they didn't have to go build it in
antarctica where we can hardly get
research ships to go and it's really
expensive and how do you build at the
bottom of the ocean
so the thing is doctor is is it not
effective to do something at the source
rather than try then when the water
levels have risen so high to build sea
walls around the world's global coastal
cities which will cost thousands and
trillions of dollars
100
we should be doing something at the
source but you know what the sources in
this case the source is climate change
the source of that
is greenhouse gas polluting gas
emissions and that by the way is
man-made let's let's just please please
because there are many people who once
you say that greenhouse gas they're like
well you know water vapor is the most
and i'm like shut up it's us we're doing
it
absolutely
yeah chuck's bedside manner right trying
to convert people
all right doctor how
let's pick on florida gary we gotta
begin to land the plane so all right so
let's pick on florida before we get to
the airport and um
say what would it take to flood the
coastal cities in florida therefore give
chuck a big smile on his face because
that means tom brady can't play football
anymore
well i don't know if any of you have
visited coastal florida recently but
they are already dealing with a lot more
flooding than they used to so that's
kind of a question that's like
already in the past um we're already
seeing increased flooding all along the
coast the gulf coast of the us
especially hard hit
and um when we look at the future we're
sort of at this little point here and
those futures diverge all of them seas
continues to rise
but in some of them those seas rise way
faster and way more and that difference
that is human action that's terrible so
anyway um with respect to the coastal
areas of florida um those areas are
beautiful and good is there any way that
we could skip over them and flood the
interior where all the crazy people live
well
i'm just gonna tell you that actually
i i i'm guessing you you were hoping
that would just be a joke but i'm
telling you when you raise sea levels
that also influences groundwater and you
can actually get interior flooding that
is a result of sea level rise but
climate change is also changing
precipitation and we got lots of
flooding due to different rain events as
well i haven't thought about this so
so
of course if the ocean levels rise
then all levels of water that are inland
will be influenced by this
and so you would have had the
might have had a certain absorbency
to accommodate a rainfall
that it won't any longer because the
water table's higher and so you'll flood
sooner than you would have you'll flood
more often than you ever did is that is
that a fair assessment yeah yeah that
that absolutely can happen in places and
also that um what you're bringing up
earlier fresh water versus salt water
suddenly we have this salty ocean water
getting into this groundwater table and
working away at the coast and we can run
into problems with our fresh drinking
water too oh my god yeah that's wow
before we before we get to to land
doctor one more question from me how
does not eating a burger
a week
help save the ice
well
one of the things as we were discussing
the source of ice loss is man-made
climate change and there are a lot of
things we can be doing to address
man-made climate change and it will
require systemic change so we can't just
look to ourselves to do all the best
things but every one of us is part of
this system so
hey if i'm gonna be part of this system
i'm gonna start to
do some more climate-friendly practices
and i'm gonna tell my friends about it
and my neighbors and my
colleagues and all the people i work
with and that's how we create this
movement so we get individual action and
systemic change and we actually move
towards this future where the air is
cleaner the water is cleaner and
everything's not melting into the ocean
oh my god oh god thank you so much oh
i'm just you know for the longest time
scientists who work
like you they were
because we need to move
policy and we need to move corporations
what they were saying was individual
action
can't really make a difference here
you're the first one to articulate it in
such a way where it's not necessarily
dependent upon us but we all have a role
to play and thank you for saying that
oh yeah absolutely because that's how we
create movements and social movements
social tipping points are a huge part of
making climate action something that
we're not even thinking about like i go
to get a car i want a big silverado
truck and the thing i get is a electric
because that's what you drive so there's
a big part of creating a system change
that is made up of all of us as
individuals working together
making our ideas ripple getting things
started locally
all right we got to end it there uh
twilight thanks for this uh it's really
fun information we've all heard of
glaciers we know rudimentary things
about them but how often are we in arms
reach of an expert
and who's devoted their life and career
to it so thanks for being on this and
and uh we should do one day a uh the
cosmic queries with her yes we get our
fans to write in we could totally fill a
show
with what we know will be people's
questions about
on this topic uh gary always good to
have you man pleasure my friend
all right chuck all right and twilight
how can we find you on social media
what's your presence there you can find
me on twitter
at twilamoon
and also at changeynice.com
all right there it is this has been
another installment of star talk
the ice edition
neil degrasse tyson as always
keep
[Music]
you